すいません はい あのちょっと聞き忘れたんですけれども
はい 先ほど仏陀に従うというところでですね
真理に従うことが真の自由
それから存在を脱出すると
存在を脱出するっていうのはどういう
こと 解脱することですね
いわゆるどんな次元で生きていたっても自由じゃないんですよ
今人間でいるんだから自由じゃないでしょうに
いくら自由自由と言ったってもね
結局は束縛されているでしょうに
これで犬になったら自由かというととんでもないでしょうに
神になったっても自由がないんですよ
だからどんな存在でも自由じゃないんです
しかし その法則を守っていると
いくらか楽なんです 我々も法律を守ると逮捕はされません
楽ですよ そういうことで
自由っていうのは輪廻を脱出すること
解脱すること いわゆる存在を脱出することなんですね
はい 他質問があるならば
はい 具体的な目標でですね
あの座の瞑想をやってるという妄想が起きないように
一日で妄想が起きないようにというふうにやるんですけど
まだいけないんですが
妄想が起きないようにっていうのはあまりにも大それた目標ですか？ いえいえ
それもそんなに大それたものじゃないんだ
なぜならば具体的だからね
妄想も具体的に捕まれる対象でしょ
この捕まれる対象を目標にするのはいいんです
解脱したいと言ったら
解脱って何でしょうかね
さっぱりわからないでしょうに
だからそこはあまり足かせになる恐れがあります
妄想を止めたいと思ってかなり長くやっているんですけども
うん どうしても出てくるんですね
それ  いえ 出てきたっても
妄想はそれなりに管理はされてます
それで観察しておりましてですね
気がついて またその元に戻りながら
例えばそれ目標なら呼吸にまた戻ります
またしばらくするとまた出るんですね
それをずっとサイコロ like のように繰り返しているんですけども
うん やっぱりそのどこか問題があるのかも長くやっているんですけど
どうしても出てくる  問題あるところももしかするとあの
ちょっといっぺんに時間を伸ばした方がいいかもしれません
1時間ではなくて ぶっ続けて 3時間もやるとかね
その時はもうもうクタクタ疲れますけど
ちょこっと首をみたくなるかもしれませんだけど
それでもう治るんです
だから瞑想方法はそういう微妙な調整はできます
例えば 30 分しか座らないんだったら
この時間足らないんです
で じゃあ 1 時間もするそうと思ったら
1時間は自分の力では持てないかもしれませんだけど
最悪感じるかもしれませんよ
それでもやってみる そうなってくると
もうすぐ心がもう成長しちゃうんです
心っていうのは面白い法則がありますよ
もう最悪ダメだ もうこれからどうにもならんという瞬間で
諦めた瞬間に成長するんです
この諦めませんよ まずしっかり決めないとやるそうと
だから簡単に飽きる 飽きちゃ
飽きちゃった状態で瞑想しちゃって瞑想になりません
やっぱりやるそうでやるんですよ
やるそうとやって やって
やって やって もうこれってどうにもならんという瞬間で諦めると
もうすぐもうどうにかなってるんです
そういう心の法則があります
ですから ちょこっと時間を伸ばしてみれば
うん はい  お釈迦様と当時のインドの方々が
お釈迦様が悟りを開かれる前にそういうものがあるということですね
お釈迦様が初めて悟られたのに
お釈迦様とか当時のインドの方々が悟りということが可能だということがどうしてわかったんですか？ うん
これはまあ 悟りっていうのはもうインド的な言葉
まあこれは日本語なんですけど
まあ人間の最終目的は何かあるんだろうという一般的な思考ですよ
まず 例えば西洋 中東の方になってくると
もう神に作られて 人間は最終的には楽園に行くべきであるという
なんとなく目的決めちゃうんですね
そこでインド世界では一神教もあったんですけど
一神教でない思考もいっぱいありまして
まあやっぱり人間はどこへ行くべきかという疑問が出てくるんですよ
それはどこへ行くべきかっていうところで
あの悟りというか もう覚醒というか
いろんな単語で精神的な何か状態であると思っていたんですね
だからまあ 悟りと単語を作っても中身は同じじゃないんです
ウパニシャッド世界では悟りっていうのは梵我一如ですから
一体感なんですよ 自分と他者のでそれぞれ違います
だからブッダが言うのは完全無執着
心は何にも依存しない
何の対象も取らない状態なんですね
だから悟りという単語は
まあそういう一般的な単語でもありましたし
例えば阿羅漢 阿羅漢というのは極一般的な言葉なんですよ
パーフェクト意味なんですよ
人間ならパーフェクトにならなくちゃいけないんだと
このパーフェクトになった人に使う言葉は阿羅漢なんです
日本語で阿羅漢ということ
だから阿羅漢の意味が忘れちゃった人々は
阿羅漢の悟りは不完全であると言うんですね
もうパーフェクトになった人はパーフェクトではありませんという矛盾な言葉なんですけど
昔はパーフェクトっていう意味で阿羅漢ですから
誰にでも使える単語なんです
だから論争もできる 一人が私は阿羅漢だしょと言ったところで
本当にあなたはパーフェクトでしょうか？と議論すれば
そういうことだから まあなんとかあるんだよという気分はあったんです
それ そのなんとか何だろうかと誰も発見しなかったんですね
だいたい仏典になってくると
このブッダが現れる時代になってくると
大勢の人々は興味的にもそういう心の境地があるんじゃないかなという
この一般常識 社会常識にもなるんだと
だからその背景でブッダが成功するんだと
いうふうに仏教伝説では書いてありますよ
だからそれは現代的な思考で見ても当たり前のことなんですね
社会の一般的な流行の目的があって
それが一人が成功しましたということなんです
この煩悩を断つことで悟り
完全智者になるんだよというところまであったんです
仏教以外も しかし そこをブッダが言うのは
あんた煩悩をなくしたら悟れるというんだけど
あんた煩悩は知ってますかと
すべて何個あるのかとかね
そういうところはブッダは違いますよ
これが煩悩で これ以上何もないんだと
全部もう取っちゃうんですね
そこはどこから生まれるのかといって
その原因を探して そこを根こそぎに切ったりする
他の宗教では 煩悩はまあなくせばいいんでしょうとか言いながら
煩悩ってどれぐらいのことをはっきりわからないんですね
そうなってくるとなくせなくなっちゃうんですね
例えば渇愛っていうのはタンハーですからね
言語ではタンハー 良くないと思う
ヒンドゥー教でもウパニシャッドテキストでもどこにでもあります
ジャイナ教典にもタンハーは良くない
トリシュナっていうのは良くないとありますよ
タンハーという単語は
辞書を引いても良くない単語なんですよ
タシーナ タンハー トリシュナ
サーストというね 渇きという状態だからね
しかしブッダだけ じゃあ渇きはどれぐらいあるのかと
これは 3つしかないんだよっていうのはブッダだけなんですよ
だからそういうところはものすごい仏教はもう想像を絶する
優れてますよ 知識的にでも心理学的にでも
だからすごい大胆なところ
だから大胆に言うんだよ
お釈迦様は これ以上も以下もありませんというところは
そこまで大胆に言うのは
この他の宗教の方々のためなんです
渇愛はそうですね あなたも渇愛は悪いと思っている
じゃあ私もそう思っているとかね
その状態では何にもなりません
だからそこを第3番目にブッダが入って入り込んで
あのね 渇愛は 3つですと
その 3つ足しなさいよと
4つありませんよとハッキリと言っておくんです
だからブッダの言葉というのは
いつでもすごい力強いし
すごい大胆なんです この大胆というのは
ブッダが傲慢という意味じゃないんです
その当時のみんな なんとなく似ている思考でいたんだからなんです
ということで  はい はい
今日の戒律の話の中でですね
私  3年前に戒律になりまして
その当時すごい酒豪でですね
清酒研究会にも入ってまして
大酒飲みだったんですけれども
長老のいろいろ本とかビデオとか見てたらですね
まあ少しずつでもやめていけばやめられるようになるんじゃないかというのを見ましてですね
実践しまして  2年前から一滴も飲まなくなりまして
今も飲んでいないんですけれども
先ほどお話の中で やっぱり今も会合とかですね
会議の後の懇親会とかで飲む機会も多いんですけれども
その中でやっぱり後輩なんかがですね
大酒飲みがいるんですよ
で かなり羽目外す人も出てくるんでね
そういう時に自分もお酒やめてですね
気持ちもすごく落ち着いたし
考え方もね すごく変わってきたんで
少しずつ自分もやめたんで
こういう効果が出てるので
あの少しずつやめた方がいいんじゃないの？みたいなですね
アドバイス 自分がやめたからっていうのをですね
出すのはあまり良くないですか？ いや
まあ親切にまあ言うのは悪くないんですよ
あの ちょこちょこと控えてみたら
能力も向上しますよと
そういうふうにね だから自分もちゃんとやめているんだから
言う権利はありますよ
言う資格 権利じゃなくて言う資格は取ってます
ですから 失礼にならない程度で言ってもよろしいんです
相手のことを本当に心配しているのならば
失礼にはならないんです
だからみんな羽目外したくなるのは
仕事でストレス溜まってるからでしょ
仕事でストレス溜まるということは
仕事がうまくいってないということなんですね
ということは あまり能力を発揮できなかったということなんですよ
ですから 脳細胞をしっかり整理整頓しておくと
仕事はうまくいっちゃうし
それでストレスは溜まることは少なくなっちゃうし
その分は酒に逃げることも減ったりいくしという循環だよと
いくらなんでもあんた方は能力向上したいでしょうと
仕事はスムーズにやりたいでしょうと
その方が気分いいでしょうとね
だから酒の目的じゃないでしょうと
仕事はとかね  あまり出しゃばったことは言えませんだけど
こういうやり方もありますよと
いうふうな程度でよろしいと思います
はい ありがとうございます
時間を延ばした方がいいというのは
具体的にはタイマーをつけてですね
40 分でタイマーが鳴るようにしてるんですけども
チェックしないでやってみたいです
40 分だったら 1時間半にすれば
すいません はい 五戒の中で不忠盗戒って盗んじゃいけないっていう戒律があるんですけど
私はその 例えば単純にものを盗むんじゃなくて
例えば会合にいる時に一人が遅れてきたら
もうそれで進まなくなっちゃう
それも盗むということだと思いますし
あと車でも 例えば走ってて抜いて
この人は抜かれたくないのに抜いて割り込んだら
やっぱり盗むってことになっちゃうと思う
そういう意味で 不忠盗戒っていうのはすごいこう
なんか幅広いと思うんですけど
それ考えすぎ これあまりにも自分の思考で考えるところで盗むということの定義がありますから
これ持ち物に対してなんです
盗むべきものの対してなんですよ
ただ でもその車でも抜かれたくないって執着があるところに入っていったら
やっぱりその  道路はみんなのもので
抜かれたくないと思う気持ちはダメです
なんでそんな気持ち取るんですかね
それは考えすぎ もう抜かれたいと思って早く行きたい人に道を開けない
開けないということもすごいひどい男なんです
である日本の方が自分の国で車を乗せて
自分の車であちこち連れて行ったんですけど
すごい道路は狭いし 車は道路いっぱいでしょうし
それでも私の運転するやつがものすごい早く行くんですよ
すごいスピード出して
私もいろんなことがあってね
もうすごい合わせているんだから
もうその子はよく合わせてくれます
それでこの日本の方がびっくりするんですよ
これいくら考えたっても抜くことできないんだよと
この道路ではと よく抜けていくもんだなと
それで次にびっくりしたのは
前に行きたいと人が思った途端
前にいるある車がちゃんと避けてくれるんですよ
道を開けてあげるんです
向こうはそういう考えなんですよ
自分はこういうスピードでいる
行く 後ろの車が先に行きたいんですね
はい どうぞと 時々このちょこっと厳しい前の運転手さんがちょこっと苦労して開けてくれる時もありますよ
その場合はちゃんと客船でピッっと一回鳴らしてありがとうと言うんです
そこで後ろの人もピッっと鳴らして
もうどうしたことはないという
そういう挨拶までするんです
で どけどけというピピピと鳴らすことはあまりしないんです
だからこのまあ 車の場合はすごい関係ないんで
これ道路は公のもので
誰にでも権利がありますから
まあ法則破ることは誰にね
破ることは誰にもできませんだけど
盗むっていうことは持つっていうことと関係ありますよ
例えば会合があって ３
時間の会合で参加する人にみんなに 2万円なんとか払いますよということになったところで
一人が 30 分遅れてきて
それでも 2万円取ると
これ 30 分遅れた理由によって盗むになるかならないかっていうことになるんです
自分にはどうしても管理できない原因で 30 分遅れたならば
本人の責任じゃないんです
先生  あんなどうという会合じゃないんだから
30 分 １時間遅れたってもね
まあいいんじゃないかと
という感じでいけばダメです
そこで自分の国の国会で国会に参加するたびに
日本ではわかりませんだけど
結構金くれるんですよ
議員たちに で それから
給料もあります 月々の
それで 1ヶ月間 一回だけでも議会に参加すれば
給料はちゃんと丸ごともらえます
で 議会に参加するたびに
また参加費別々にくれるんです
ボロ儲けですけど 議員はね
それであの連中はどうやって法律作ってるんでしょうかというと
あの国会が 始まる前に議員たちが入らなくちゃいけないんですけど
後から入ったってもどうったことないし
とにかく自分が入ったという参加した信号だけ入れておいて
それからどこか出て行くとか
どこか別などこかへ行って
何か別なことをやったりして
で また次の日も来て ちょこっと顔を出してまた出て行って
特にあの あの あのバジェットいうあの １年間のあれ
何て言いますか え 予算
あれって厳しいでしょうね
結構時間かけてやってますから
項目ごとに その時はみんなもうただただ
その時その時もうちょこっと顔を出して出て行って
喋る人だけ国会に残って残っていて
で あの投票する時だけみんなサーッと投票しますよと信号出ますから
その時サーっと行って投票を出してまた出て行くとか
あれっていうのは盗みでしょ
まあサインだけしちゃえば
もう今日の参加費もらいますよという
だからこの持つものに関係ありますよ
それ以外は  やっぱり日本の人はやっぱりさっき道路のあれでもすごい執着っていうか
がありすぎってことですよね
これ性格悪いんですよ
もうあえて世界でも誰と比較したって
日本は これを考え直した方がいいんですよ
いつでも決まり文句で
日本は行儀が良くてすごいできてる国やってのは
そこが落とし穴ですよ
だから自分をちょこっと考え直すってことはしないんです
で 日本の運転のものすごく素晴らしい行儀がいいんですよ
なぜかというと 厳密に校則で決まって縛ってるんだからなんです
なのにいつでも何か事故を起こす
日本のこんなに整理整頓している道路で事故を起こすはずがないんです
事故 事故を起こすするなっても瞬時の反射もできないし
ちょっとダメで危ないんですよ
だからあの道路に執着っていうのも考えられません
私には 私はこの高速道路ででもすごい渋滞状態になっちゃうと
私にとってはそれがすごく面白くて
ぐちゃぐちゃ文句言うんだったら
ただの漫才であってね
まあこの人 何か車の会社の名前とか見えるでしょ
それでこの会社 この会社の人
なんで今日に限ってこの道路に入ったんですかね
これはわざといじめじゃないんでしょうかとかね
もうくだらんことを言ってるんです
別にいじめも何でもないんですけど
ただみんなたまたま混雑してるだけで
まあこれで待ってる時間は楽しく過ごすんです
今日雨も降ってるのに
家でテレビ見た人を見ていた方が良かったのに
あの人にとかね そんなくだらんこと言いながら楽しくその時間過ごすんであって
道路に執着するっていうことはね
すごい性格 悪いんですよ
クラクション鳴らしちゃうと降りてきて殺すわ
大変です そちらには盗むっていうことは入りません
それはもうただ単に行儀悪い
はい ではまあ終了しましょうか
それでは回向の文 向こうの三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 教師 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
サッビーティオーリワンジャントゥサッベルーゴーウィナッセットゥマーテーバワットワンテラーヨースキーディーナーイコーバワーバウォトゥサッベマンガナンラ
ッカントゥサッベデーヴァタサッベブッダヌバーウェーナーサッベダンマーヌバーウェーナーサッベサンガーヌバーウェーナーサダー
スッティーバワントゥティアビワーダナシーリッサーニッチャンワッダーパチャイノーチャッタールーダンナーワッダンティーアーイワンノースカンバラン
どうもありがとうございます